okay what's going on guys this is rob
and we are back with venom yes we are
with venom by donnie kates and uh yeah i
i still love this story and honestly the
ending to this is kinda nuts so i have
no idea what direction dining case is
going in well i kind of have a general
idea but regardless like i am i am
ecstatic about this whole run so picking
up where we left off last time one of
the things to keep in mind we kind of
have two plots going at the same time
right or two sets of events that are
unfolding at the same time on one side
we have alkamax now alkamax of course
we've talked about them before here on
the channel we haven't gone super
in-depth and we don't really need to go
super in-depth here but the important
thing to understand is that alkamax well
they're a pretty shady corporation i
mean they've got their hands in
basically everything but they're kind of
an answer to the question what would
happen if some major conglomerate uh
basically existed for the purpose of
using all their technology and
advancement to basically do shady things
uh so they're like amazon essentially
the big difference here though is that
alchemax focuses largely on like like
weapons technology different things like
that and the goal of alchemax is to
basically understand how symbiotes work
so they can find a way to counter
symbiotes remember in the aftermath of
the king in black is basically a giant
arms race everybody started to realize
the technological capabilities of
utilizing symbiotes and now everybody's
trying to get their hands on them the
other part of that is the return of
carlton drake and the life foundation
now we don't really know exactly how it
is that carlton drake managed to come
back we don't really even know why the
life foundation has returned we
certainly just know there's the absent
throne this just kind of shady
organization that seems to operate
behind the scenes that's basically
funding all these different groups and
organizations and the current efforts of
the life foundation is to basically push
the symbiote beyond its limits exactly
what that means is something only time
will tell but with dylan the son of
eddie brock kind of being the star of
the show that he alongside his symbiote
basically had kind of been kidnapped
right so sleeper the city that he has
along with him that little pet that
little cat that symbiote cat that's
sleeper right it's really more of like a
spy symbiote than anything else but
they've basically been taken by alcamax
and so venom is effectively hot on the
trail now one of the funny things about
this is that the venom symbion has
largely been struggling since basically
the death of eddie brock right in the
aftermath uh really the beginning of
this story to be quite frank um now
eddie brock we'll talk about him here in
a minute but the whole thing about this
is that with the symbiote i wouldn't go
as far as to say that it was heavily
reliant on eddie brock but it had built
a bond with eddie brock and eddie brock
basically dying or disappearing has just
kind of left the the symbiote feeling
abandoned and as a result of that it
really begins to kind of wonder what its
purpose is right and why it's doing
these things to basically help dylan
right what role does dylan play more so
than that it begins talking about the
idea of consequences and that's kind of
the funny thing here right it says that
dylan made his choices that dylan chose
to leave the venom symbiote behind
knowing the venom symbiote was his best
measure of protection right the one
thing that could basically always keep
dylan safe that everywhere the symbiote
turns is being abandoned in one form or
another and so it's kind of interesting
because it's like why should i go after
dylan right why should i go after this
kid and why should i save his life and
there's merit to that question one of
the the best phrases that i've ever
heard was during the events or really
during the video game uh star wars
knight to the old republic 2 when crea
had this thing where she was talking
about asking for aid and she made this
case of like charity right saying that
charity is actually a bad thing because
by giving somebody something they
haven't earned all you've done is make
them a target for somebody else and
because they didn't earn the thing they
have they won't know how to keep the
thing they have and so when the time
comes where circumstance or people
attempt to take that thing away from
them they'll be unable to fight to keep
it and so she says beware of charity and
kindness lest you do more harm with an
open hand than with a clenched fist and
so it's one of those things where it's
like dylan made his choices dylan will
become stronger because of his ability
to overcome his choices or he will die
and so it's really kind of pushing him
to the limit to see what he's really
capable of now of course the venom
symbiote obviously ends up deciding to
go after dylan
which is kind of an interesting thing
but in the midst of it all suddenly he's
met by the forces of the life foundation
basically one of them wielding this new
new kind of technology that allows them
to overcome symbiotes specifically by
using a spear that basically emits a
sonic pulse which as you guys know sound
and fire are the weaknesses of symbiotes
so this is a cool little thing but
switching over to to dylan and the
alcamax lab dylan is just being
experimented on this is one of the the
interesting things about this is that
liz allen puts on this very cold and and
very almost kind of dark and
disconnected attitude when it comes to
this and in the realm of science that's
kind of what you have to do right you
have to remove emotion from the equation
and you have to come to it from the
perspective of there is a goal that
we're trying to achieve it doesn't mean
lose your humanity it suddenly just
means you cannot allow yourself to be
emotional in conducting an experiment
because your emotions can taint the
experiment as much as external factors
can and so with liz allen operating in
this capacity understand here this is
not liz allen forcing herself to do that
she really is a jerk
right even you know if you go and you
read the spider-man comics by nick
spencer and even even with dan slott and
people up to that point sometimes she
was really cool sometimes she was really
really mean but but have no have no
illusions here right her default state
is to be cold her default state is to be
emotionless to be removed that's who she
is as a person and so because of that
it's one of these interesting things
because it really shows you what she's
about and that's where she kind of says
like the experiment has to go on right
when they're saying like well i mean
dylan's kind of being pushed to his
limits her response is we have to keep
going and notice this when she leaves
right and when she kind of allows
herself to just sort of sit for a minute
her response isn't i can't believe i'm
doing this to a kid her response is what
have you gotten yourself into right it's
not really remorse for what she's
putting dylan through it's i may have
bitten off more than i can chew here
because in reality all it's going to
take is just a cracked piece of glass
and then suddenly all hell breaks loose
when the symbiotes come pouring out and
so because of that kind of switching
back over to venom there's not a whole
lot doing here if anything it's designed
to show that the life foundation has
learned a lot since the old venom lethal
protector story lines right when when
they were trying to capture the
symbiotes creating symbiotes of their
own different things along those lines
not only that this guy's pretty intense
and being able to like overcome these
different symbiotes or at least being
able to overcome venom and one of the
things about this that makes it so
interesting is that it's not really a
circumstance whereby they are there to
basically destroy venom right like
carson's whole thing is like i was told
to come after you so that's basically
what i'm doing and when the venom to me
it manages to make its escape carlton
drake of course appears by way of like a
monitoring drone basically and says no
carson let it go because their goal is
not to destroy the samia their goal is
to push the symbiote again why they're
doing this we don't fully know and so
switching back over to dylan dylan
begins to to realize the totality of the
choice that he made right that he got
himself into this terrible situation and
begins kind of reaching out to his dad
now of course eddie brock as far as
dylan's aware is basically dead and by
all standards of measurement he is right
so it's really more of him just kind of
musing to himself than anything else but
in saying like dad i'm lost right i'm in
pain and i'm afraid when times were
rough i knew you'd come out fighting for
the both of us it was the thing i always
held on to if you're still out there
eddie brock i could use a little help
now here's the irony behind this in
truth dylan always had his dad to back
him up and so because of that dylan
never really had to experience what it
meant to make it in the world on his own
he never really had to experience what
it meant to become a better version of
himself he always had a safe space and i
firmly believe people don't really
become or really understand what they're
capable of until you remove plan b from
the equation until there is no backup
plan until there is no way for you to to
make it on your own except for your your
wits and your fortitude and that's it
that's all you have right sink or swim
live or die succeed or fail and that's
it it's only under those circumstances
that people become better anything
outside of that and you'll never get 100
because even if it's only in the back of
their mind they know somebody will save
me and that's not really a source of
strength if anything that holds you back
and so what's kind of funny about this
is that even in the face of that eddie
brock still comes to the rescue of dylan
which again is something that i think
takes away from what would make dylan
truly capable now the funny thing about
this is that eddie brock showing up this
is cool because what it means is that
eddie brock is still alive and well but
seemingly only in like a spiritual form
or only in the symbiotes because
remember in the aftermath of the king in
black that eddie brock was able to kind
of exist simultaneously right like yes
he had an actual physical form yes he
did sit there and yes he could see
through the eyes of all the symbiotes
across the universe but it's one of
those things where as time progresses he
becomes part and parcel to them so even
though his physical body is destroyed
that kind of telepathic link that sort
of control over the symbiotes basically
allows them to live on and so while he's
not able to maintain a true physical
form and in fact could only do so for a
very short period of time he appears
just long enough to reassure dylan and
to say look archer and venom are the
only ones that you can trust and when
dylan reveals that archer was the one
that set him up and led him into this
circumstance in the first place the
response of eddie is okay well then i
guess venom's the only one you can trust
but understand as much as you may have
disdain for that venom symbiote as much
as you might not like that venom
symbiote understand that symbiote will
come for you right it will come for you
and it will save you and it will do that
because that symbiote is part of me and
i know that symbiote probably better
than it knows itself that that symbiote
is not like all the others that it's
different right it's experience things
that make it different from the other
symbiotes you are my offspring you are
my son you are part and parcel to me and
so is that symbiote and so for no other
reason than to honor my memory or
because it still cares about me that
symbiote will find you and it will
rescue you and so ultimately eddie brock
is the one that basically frees dylan
which is just a ridiculously amazing
moment and then in turn that venom
symbiote just comes rolling in right
just comes comes running into that place
now of course this also leads to dylan
like knocking out one of the scientists
with a with a fire extinguisher which is
kind of cool and then as soon as as soon
as he's like literally cornered right
like once he gets to sleep where it's
like okay we gotta free this guy but as
soon as he's cornered right and like all
these guns are pointing at him liz allen
and all those guys are there the venom
symbiote comes in and it immediately
bonds to eddie brock and the response of
liz allen is crap right and like all
these guys are basically screwed because
at that point the venom symbiote takes
over now one of the things about this
that's so interesting is the nature of
this this kind of conversation right
this sort of narrative this monologue
that says the sequence of complex
biological changes that dylan's unique
physiology had set in motion when they
first bonded on the night of eddie
brock's fiery demise finally bears its
glorious teeth as liz allen and all
those around her begin to realize
carlton drake that the symbiote they all
knew as venom is turning into something
new right it's evolving it's growing
it's changing because of what the life
foundation had done to it by way of
poking and prodding right pushing it to
what we could call its mental limits and
so what you do is you switch over to
carlton drake and find out that he's
basically talking to meridius now for
those of you guys who are kind of like
okay who in the heck is meridius we
don't know we have no idea what this
guy's deal is right all we know is that
seemingly when eddie brock had quote
unquote died was kind of just yanked
into the ethereal timeline that
ultimately was one of those things where
one he had been approached or had met
with king the conqueror and kang was
like what you're doing he was going to
end everything and that meridius was
seemingly on the other part of this
right that meridia seemed to basically
override eddie brock's ability to
control the symbiotes but meridius
himself seems to exist in the far-flung
future so we don't really know this
guy's deal where he comes from what he's
capable of we don't know if he's some
version of dylan we don't know if he's
some future version of eddie we don't
know if he is the evolution of the venom
symbiont and he's literally just
solidifying his own existence we have no
clue what's going on with this guy all
we know is that seemingly this guy is
the one behind the scenes that's been
having carlton drake that one restored
him back to how he looks now but when he
was just kind of torn apart and left in
a ruinous state previously and two is
the reason why the life foundation's
doing what it's doing to continue to
poke and prod at the venom symbiote more
so than that he says everybody here is
playing a part and this part will all
come together as a cohesive hold right
dylan being taken by alcamax being poked
and prodded by liz allen being basically
subjected to torture that is dylan
brock's role in the here and now that's
liz allen's role in the here and now
alchemix that's their role your job in
hiring carson and having carson
basically chase after and torment the
venom symbiote right torturing it
periodically fighting it so on and so
forth that's your role to play in the
here and now and i will play my part as
well so again what he ends up doing is
basically summoning this new symbiote
known as bedlam which looks amazing like
he's just this gigantic red and black
symbiote i mean really he's just all red
with like little bits of black like
black nails and stuff like that but it
looks awesome we don't know if this was
a symbiote that was like created by
meridius maybe it kind of looks like it
was but literally he was just like go
and find dylan and torment this kid
right push this kid to the to his
absolute limits this is cool i'm excited
to see where this goes but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace
you